leave motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to be
resourceful find mentors and value your
time with Daymond John and my take on
his top ten roses success vol 3
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be resourceful when you were
again in the early days yeah
at one point you only had 10 shirts mmm
how did you utilize the power of broke
to get the word out so you know when you
you know Jay Abraham who you know is
really my mentor he loves to say opium
is other people's manufacturing manpower
marketing mentors and you can make money
off other people's mistakes and I took
inventory of myself and I knew I wanted
to get into this area of business but my
inventory was that my liabilities were I
knew nothing about manufacturing but my
assets were that everybody was shooting
these little videos around the
neighborhood they weren't like these big
ditty videos at a million dollars I mean
this guy this was like you know guy with
a little camcorder or something and I
knew that these people wanted they
needed clothing and when they would have
the Nike send stuff to them Nike didn't
appreciate them so I would go to the set
and see an LL Cool J and I would be I
would still in said 18 hours I get
kicked off with three or four of those
sets but the one time that somebody
allowed me to put a shirt on them I put
a shirt on them and then I would take it
back and I would keep putting on
different rappers and different rappers
and different taking it back in and I
made sure that I didn't dryclean these
things so they made sure they gave them
back because they stank so I knew right
now but these videos start to rotate and
you know corporate America didn't
understand the power of videos at that
time and I started to come known as a
huge cult gummy meanwhile I'm still a
waiter in Baldwin Long Island
and I have these ten little stinky
t-shirts in my basement but I was doing
something I love I would have went on
those video sets for free I was talking
to a video chick I was eating the free
food over there I was watching ol Dirty
Bastard be ol Dirty Bastard so you know
I would have paid to be in those sets
yeah I'll do something I look rule
number two
find mentors I used to go to a corner
store at the end of after working after
school excuse me a nice guy sweep up and
this guy named Tim on the corner so he's
a veteran and he used to show me how he
dealt with inventory how he dealt with
his customers and I always say that
everybody's always looking for these big
huge mentors when this mentor is next to
you every single day in the hood there's
somebody who's had a how to store
anything for the last 10 20 years they
they understand the fundamentals of
business they understand you know you
know you either have to decrease cost
increase sales they went through
economic competitions they went through
taxes and changes I mean those people
you know they have the fundamentals you
can learn all the basics you know life
is a series of mentors then you go to
another one and another one then
hopefully you get so far in life that
you can reverse mentor the ones who've
been mentoring you because you know
you're bringing
todays way of business to them rule
number three value time you got garyvee
in here Tom Maynard Grant Cardone our
saws in here and card Oh mr. 10x you got
guess we're speaking out the event
together yeah yeah we were there last
year Oh grant him in this book he says
time is so valuable that he'll set a
meeting at 9:06 and be there at 9:06 and
be over at 9:15 man so what does that do
that puts everybody else on their best
behavior and regards to time they'll
know I ain't gonna come in at 9:00 and
float around now I know six we're on
yeah and when you start valuing those
you know 1440 minutes you have with the
day or eighty six thousand six hundred
sixty Seconds you have a good day when
you start scheduling and understanding
the value that you get the most out of
your day rule number four play it smart
when LL Cool J and some famous artists
started to wear your clothes you were
still full-time at Red Lobster
I was full-time you know because we've
we seen too many movies where it says
you know go balls to the wall burn every
Bridge oh by the way other people's
money it's rekha ball that's bull right
the bottom line is don't quit your day
job all right because you know here's
what it was happening as a later relapse
or maybe I made 30 or $40,000 right but
if I did that which I did for five years
and I got I would I would work my 60
hours at Red Lobster that I put in
another maybe 15 or 20 hours working on
FUBU but if I had to pay myself for
those five years that would have been
$200,000
now I'm 200,000 I would I had $200,000 I
had medical I was eating as many shrimp
as I would like I was using my network
at Red Lobster to get things out of it
you know how they I was learning from
the net the Red Lobster network of their
corporation in their books on how they
do business and I was able to do my
business longer and and go through the
pitfalls of it and the business started
to call me I started to now work 20% on
the business 80% right laughter then all
of a sudden 80% on the business and 20%
there but you know all these people who
hear all those stories about you know
take our large loans and just go for it
it's it's a lie they should never do
that also if you want to learn from
other successful black entrepreneurs
check out my 254 black excellent series
it's free the link to join is in the
description below why are you doing
things you have to ask yourself right
and that is your discipline right rule
number five constantly improve yourself
what are some of the common attributes
that you see that successful people
billionaires or people worth hundreds of
millions what is it that they have
they're always trying to educate
themselves constantly trying to educate
themselves they're trying to find out
how could they be better a stronger or
what they do when I look at the
billionaire is the funny thing about the
billionaires is a lot of times they they
they go around and they they write down
new ways of saving money on taxes cuz if
you really think about this if you're a
billionaire and you have a company
that's bringing in another four hundred
million dollars right instead of them
thinking about how to do a new company
they think well why am I gonna pay 200
million in taxes how can I work harder
to keep that instead of creating
something new so they don't spread
themselves too thin right why create
something new uh-huh to make what I can
say right now that I already got uh-huh
all right so they think that way when
I'm in the room with billionaires the
you know it's funny I
I think I post this other day I'm in the
room with dudes who have a little bit of
money they talk about how much money
they spent on cars or parties when I'm
in the room with billionaires they talk
about how much money they gave away
right because that's gonna come back to
them in a whole different way I also
find that they make a lot of mistakes
they don't spend themselves too thin but
they keep trying new things because what
that does that forces them to educate
themselves on on what's gonna work rule
number six give and love a lot of us
were raised with the theory that
business has to be hard and cut the road
and you got to be like you know jr.
Ewing and Dallas or Michael Douglas on
Wall Street and that's the only way to
go it's you know it's Rekha ball and my
life I'm here because of a lot of giving
people you know I'm here because of
those teachers that believed in a little
dyslexic boy or my stepfather came in my
life at the age of 15 who who is of the
Jewish faith and it gave me a worldview
to understand that love doesn't come in
a color or a gender and the people are
amazing and and I got to understand
something about white people that first
of all they're you know
white black yellow love doesn't come to
Jenner and white people is just as
screwed up as black people - right and
he made it very human but I remember his
brother his brother was the lead
attorney - you know in America to fight
for the abolishment of apartheid and the
freeing of Mandela and when I see that
that people of all color and people like
that are giving and you know we we don't
get to see the human aspect of society
in the beautiful part of it and then
when I was growing up you know in
business you would think it would be my
competition caulk and I who created you
know who's really a prominent figure in
urban apparel he was one of the first
people to to to introduce me to stores
and help me well right so I I came up
seeing people who were giving I didn't
come up seeing cutthroat people maybe I
have blinders on and I wouldn't deal
with them yeah so I think that that's a
lesson that people need to know outside
because everybody's trying to put on
this facade like you got to be so tough
you can't you can't be tough to be on
the team rule number seven be patient so
many people want these instant results
and it's like
the way to do it there's a real I listen
every every overnight success is taken
15 years and that's just the way it goes
and they've just watched too many people
you know you know who tells them all
this the people that are trying to take
their money you know
the people the people that are trying to
take your money work twice as hard so
they go take this magic pill you're
gonna lose weight you're gonna I'm gonna
educate you and what just come to my
seminar by $100,000 pack those are the
people that are full of crap and and
other people out there who don't want to
put in the work
unfortunately nobody's gonna help you
remember eight schedule yourself first
as I shared in um in rise & grind they
scheduled their family first date you
know like because it is we get up you
know listen we're always scheduling
everything else with time to be on the
train with time to be at a meeting with
time be on a conference call the time
ago that dinner with a bunch of clients
so you don't even really like to talk to
anyway they schedule every single they
schedule their health so they get up in
the morning they schedule their doctor's
they schedule their family and then they
go ahead and schedule the other things
other people's priorities but they
schedule themselves first and foremost
rule number nine visualize your goals
can you this is another thing I like on
the show if it's possible like people
have been willing to go there I'm not
suggested just a little bit of pressure
but not too much share one of those
tingles I know you get some big ones and
it knows knows a financier but no as a
fun oh no no so so you're one of those
ten goals that you read everyday it's
easy one of the ten goals is I will I
will do down to a hundred and seventy
that's my fighting weight and you know
after like I said the medicine and and
the things I've had to figure things out
but I will get down to 173 pounds by is
April 15th and I will do this by
drinking a bottle eight glasses of water
a day not eating any fried foods meats
and not eating after 6:00 p.m. unless
it's after a workout I will also put in
10,000 steps a day and in return for
this health I'll be able to stay around
in my daughter's lives and walk them
down the aisle incredible so what
happens is when I get to eight April 15
I can be 180 it doesn't matter I reset
the goal for another six months but you
have to visualize yourself after when
you do because you start because then at
dinner then I write then I say meditate
and what you have to visually look at is
me walking my daughters down the aisle
so careful yeah you have to visualize it
because something like losing weight for
the sake losing weight it's hard
motivation I think Tony member I think
Tony does a great job with this Tony
Robbins like how can you associate
something insanely positive with the
results of that goal and see yourself in
that moment yeah I think that that's
powerful and you'll number 10 the last
one you for a very special bonus clip is
redefine success
final question what's your definition
great
yes you know well the quick answer is
the one that everybody knows which is
what success is you know doing something
you love every day but my I think my
greatness you know being satisfied
yourself me able to sleep at night
because of the journey that you've taken
and just really being able to sleep at
night and not having to not having to
say man I shouldn't have done that and
now I got to correct myself like you
know like just being able to I can I
sleep really really good at night yeah I
do and I'm glad that I do because my
life you know growing up enough a tough
neighborhood I could have made other
turns and I and I you know I was very
tempted as a kid but just being able
that that's what it because that so many
people think that money is success and
it's not it really isn't and I'm not
saying that cuz I got a couple of
dollars you know what I mean is it
really isn't I know people that have I
don't have a pot to piss in they're the
happiest you can ever imagine now I have
a special bonus cup from Daymond on how
to start your new habits now but before
that is time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go
question number one how do you need to
redefine success number two where do you
need to schedule yourself first and
number three how will you constantly
improve yourself this week and if you
promise to take action after watching
this video we don't just watch videos
anymore we do something after watching
them give me a hash tag believe down in
the comments make that promise to
yourself and then get to work
I adjust my habits every six months if I
can as I take inventory begin in the
years coming up yep or it's happened or
well you know whatever this is gonna air
you know I know that you may keep it for
a very good time when people really need
it well we started doing this rise &
grind challenge a month prior to the top
of the year and as you know you've been
supporting it and the reason why is that
people in the beginning of the year get
out of the gate the race they go oh I'm
gonna wait till the first of the year
I'm gonna start I'm gonna I'm gonna
start that habit then I just start a
habit then November 18th you're like oh
in six weeks yeah you got a
all right now if you guys start warming
up and you have to take inventory and
start making that judgment so that in
the beginning of the year you've already
started to adjust your performance not
start your performance and now you're
really ready to go
if you want ten more rules from Daymond
John check out the last video I made
unto him the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there
you think somebody in the world of
government something of that is going to
save you and you're not changing at all
and you're not finding new friends that
are doing things